[Music]
along with us thank you for being here
thank you for having me
all right so a better help
Korona online therapy we only have 20
minutes but I want to talk about this
for an hour what is better help and then
let's dive into why this is so relevant
in March of 2020 we have a 7,000 and we
connect people who are looking for
mental health help with one of these
licensed therapists based on their needs
and preferences where they can go to
counseling online pretty similar to the
one they would have in a
brick-and-mortar but with four options
of communication messaging which is a
synchronous you said I was the CHEO
therapist anytime you want it'll be like
email get a response usually singly okay
after or you schedule like sessions over
phone video or checked we have around
little with two million
interactions every month all months in
Corona definitely anything but with
usual as people need more if you need
more care in help given the stress
anxiety and now even loneliness with the
shelter in place to most States and of
course the inability to actually go to
see it
he wanted to okay so it way too many
questions
and I have to go back a little bit now
you're not coming from the therapy world
you're not a psychologist and did you
even come from healthcare general in
before no no no how did you get to build
this so I'm coming from consumer
products being in this space for 18
years now of interacting with consumers
on marketplaces and different kind of
services and I'm not coming from
counseling I'm not coming from
healthcare there's a whole debate about
whether farmers should come from the
domain from outside of the domain
definitely lots of examples
uber Airbnb and you name it better
health how that were founded by people
who came outside of the domain there are
some advantages that fresh thinking
usually more life thought that is
aligned with what consumers want rather
than what the system is used to provide
and maybe convenience the system by the
traditional way obviously we have
therapists on the team and we all the
clinical stuff I'm not making any
clinical decisions whatsoever but our
concept from day one was we wanted to
create something that people actually
wanted people who use because the stand
to be argued with for therapy and that's
not currently related is it's a huge
deed of a lot of people but most people
actually don't use that so if you broke
your leg are you coughing today you're
going to see a doctor in 90% plus of the
cases but most people who struggle with
mental health even very significant
struggles will avoid going to to therapy
so you have enough research shows that
you have our own 25% at any given time
as a serious mental health issue that
should be addressed by a professional
but they didn't even time very
would actually go to why it was
expensive it's inaccessible it's
inconvenient I experienced this myself
when socially unacceptable sometimes
there's a lot of stigma and experts
myself like when I thought yeah maybe
the last days of my previous company
before the better hope I want to see a
therapist and I thought okay that's that
should be easy it was anything but easy
so it's really a very very needed
service therapy as a whole that can
change people's time it's really amazing
how people can change and sometimes
pretty quickly with with the help of a
true professional that is training and
has been afraid expertise but still so
few people actually use them so our
approach and that may be different from
approach by other companies especially
in the last two or three years was not
to disrupt therapy let's not say oh
we're going to do AI a whole different
way of therapy which of the exact
opposite of our team said we want there
is a tried-and-true science that has
studied them and proved over so many
years we're going to keep it as it is
it's the same therapist that you've seen
brick-and-mortar clinics it's the same
talk of of interactions and in gold what
which changing what were disrupting is
the delivery mechanism so it's the way
people communicate with a therapist to
make it more accessible more convenient
and eventually also more okay so you
know I'm one of the biggest advocates I
think in the world for for therapy and
practicing in myself with a professional
and I believe that every person in the
world needs to see a therapist because
it's a having the subjective persona
that's able to help you reflect on what
you're feeling and believing I think
it's just it's it's a privilege and that
that the behalf and unfortunately most
people in the world can't afford it or
it's not accessible and so what you're
doing is amazing but you're also making
a lot of money I'm sure you are millions
of you said two million sessions two
million sessions a month
and and I'm guessing I'm I remember that
what was the last number to be shared
with me the total number of sessions
that were to better help insane how do
you balance this idea that you're
creating a business that is you know at
the end of it it's it's a good business
it's social good you're helping so many
people at the same time you're making
money do you find any contradiction
there do you is the people challenge you
on that sometimes there's always the
notion of oh you're making you know you
making money of people's misery but
that's I think coming into so many
professions from doctors to mechanics
yeah anacs like money when your body
breaks that's why people hate the
insurance companies right yeah we
provide a solution and definitely feel
comfortable especially that we make it
much more affordable but yes many love
is it a touchy topic I think and smarter
people said it before me that the
for-profit model is when you can make it
work it's actually what brings the most
value to mankind maybe it's a fortune
that's the way it is but that's that's
reality so if you can make a sustainable
business and make good that's perfect
but we do recognize that we have you
know extra responsibility here which was
why for example we have a very very
extensive financial aid program so if
you sign a service if you can't afford
that service we provide financial aid in
very various counts we keep paying
therapists the same a therapist are
unaware that even you may be getting
financial aid because we think that they
should focus under under the job and we
subsidize we give tons of a free service
to you know when there's
a time of nature disaster or in the time
of Khurana we also give some groups of
free or very discounted service so we
try to help wherever we can but yes
we're a for-profit corporation yeah we
also need to support the known I think
it's just I think it's completely right
I mean I completely agree with that and
and and I love this this idea of a
win-win situation and and really you're
creating incentives for both groups to
maximise on it and you know I got to
start working recently at hippo
insurance and I get to see firsthand and
you insurance company and you know just
the word insurance makes some people
vomit but all of a sudden you're seeing
a new type of company come up and really
try to think how can we make the user
experience better so that they don't see
us as the enemy but as a friend and I
think I'm learning a lot through that
experience and I'm really making
analogies to what's happening with
better help and that's why I also really
love what you guys are doing and now you
provide value to the end user that we
get every day sometimes five sometimes
ten these days many more than that
emails from PGI so what your change or
stage with their lives this is really
the big joy of coming to work here a lot
of companies trying to bring down you
but when you do that in such a direct
way when you actually change something
very fundamental and someone sighs
someone lies that's that's really
amazing and that what keeps us very
motivated I mean alone you can literally
fill up your whole wall with tweets of
better help save my life I see that
every day on Facebook that's that that
really I don't see that about many
companies that term something saved my
life you know something made me happier
something was tasty something helped me
enjoy movies better but something saved
my life I think that's pretty special
now we're in April where hopefully soon
at the peak of Corona and how is this
how is this affecting better help what's
happening to the to the therapy world
when now all therapists have to move
online basically yes so we see several
things happening first of all our
existing
members but people that maybe Oh months
and some of them even years definitely
use the service small and we see that in
the data our model wouldn't mention that
but the model is really the consumer is
paying a flat fee a monthly fee and with
that fee they can interact with the
counselors as much as they like over
texts and messages as they need and they
can have a weekly live session over
phone video chat it's another flexible
model of what we use the service more or
less as you need without worrying on the
financials of a specific session so we
see a lot of people just use the service
more right and we're very happy that we
can help them this time they also have
an influx of a lot of new members the
number of new people that sign up with
us and start therapy with us as doubled
is every March stress and anxiety which
are the things that are relevant to run
bars most double then compared to a firm
in March of last year so that's also
destined to to the great in unlike maybe
other verticals where you have problem
of the month up but supply
cannot accommodate that or you have more
supply now that demand in our kists
specifically for this crisis it actually
played out pretty well because a lot of
more people need therapy but also a lot
of therapists are now available to
provide more services so we see first of
all we see a lot more applications of
but also the current therapists are
opening their availability more because
we have a lot of pieces I'm just doing
better but also have a private practice
we work in a school work at an agency
and of course now everything is is very
different so yes we have a lot more
demand but it also supply improved
significantly so we're pretty pretty
good shape to accommodate yeah I mean
you know every every second article that
I read is about how tech startups are
firing vehemently across the board and
then I go on Facebook and a llama toss
we're hiring aggressively please refer
to us in the company of how many in a
company of how many people 75 see
increased by almost 10% yeah yeah and we
also try to make it impacted now so for
example one of the maybe bigger startups
in Silicon Valley I'm sure you know mass
layoffs last week we made a webinar a
couple of days ago with a whole
department that just got shut down and
offered all of them to you know start a
fast-track process because we now and
and for me I want to come across as
someone taking a badge of the situation
but for us you know always wanting now
you interview someone and they look
great and they have all the
qualifications and and everything you
always have in the bekommen okay so what
why do you leave your previous work
place or yeah where you let go and
that's always kind of a second part I
need to understand the story here it's
actually very simple
yeah I'm talking about shutdown it's a
great startup it's a great company I
even know the parents so is it awesome
it's it's terrible but they're now like
people looking for a job but the fact
that I'm looking for a job is nothing to
deal with our performance yeah or they
can please just situational I'm just
saying I kind of assume that they are
performance because they worried enough
performing startup so we'll still make
an interview process and we'll make some
behind process but it's a much more
faster I think we do with a lot more
confidence yeah so so what's gonna
happen a year from now a you know I'm
looking at people having weddings over
zoom funerals over zoom and let alone is
so therapeutic immune ocation just
planning my eleven-year-old birthday
today
good thing it's not a bat mitzvah yeah
you have it here
I don't know like I'm crystal ball
thinking a lot of I think in this week I
don't know in this week I think there is
some kind of sudden realization this is
not a binary situation where we'll just
you know we're now shut down in at the
announcement of a moment we'll go back
to normal right now people starting to
realize that it's going to be a gradual
process with a lot of checks and
balances and ups and downs and pull
backs and restrictions in and that's
open act actually opening up a lot of
questions of how things are going to I
don't think you know face to face is
doomed forever I think we'll definitely
go back to them and that's great I think
only needs one of you but it definitely
should be they go face to face with some
people that feel more comfortable some
leashes are also addressed with face to
face but also refer to people in normal
times a pretty significant percent
people who sign up to better we tell
them actually only counseling is not a
great fit for you or your situation or
maybe your severity
you should go face-to-face and we
provide referrals and resources so it
should definitely be back and should be
back but I think a lot of people just
like with you know web conferencing and
doing meeting online and working
remotely we're forced to experience
other things and find out that you know
it's actually works pretty well or
better than I expected
so I think if we prove that we can
provide the quality of service that
people expect and get in traditional
formats and then it's definitely going
to have a long-term impact
but are we are we doomed to go full
virtual so I'm thinking about you know
my generation the one after me and I
mean if we look at it in 20 years
do you see your I mean I'm looking to
you as an expert on virtual relationship
right virtual communication and you know
therapy you could suggest that it's one
of the most intimate relationships if
you could form with another with a
person let alone a professional and
you're showing that it's possible and
can still be adequate well virtual so do
you think that we're the world that's
where we're headed worse at some point
we're just gonna take it for granted
that everything is virtual and doing
this physically will be kind of weird
and out of the norm 20 years is a long
long time you can look at what happened
with retail online and Amazon Erie
tailors but it still exists in still a
huge portion of Commerce's I think it's
it's we're always going to have to have
both maybe not in the same proportion we
have now and of course it's it's up to
us to prove that it works in now you
know when we started six years ago it
was a theory and then we started getting
feedback from users and counselors but
he was always kind of this really how
the distinct clinical outcomes over the
last couple years more and more studies
and more and more research started to
come specifically for online counseling
with some studies that showed that for
some areas for example depression the
very clinical outcomes not how people
feel not what people say yeah the way
you can measure their depression
symptoms the improve the reduction in
these symptoms is not only in counseling
with Mike Rettig oh wow compared to
traditional counseling so as this get
more acceptable by people in more
by my research that's definitely going
to help but I'm not I don't think I can
actually predict what happens 20 years
from now but I don't think we're going
to be virtual yeah
even in this alone before we end three
words that describe you wow that's the
reaction yeah but then I wouldn't get
that reaction three words it has to be
three adjectives or Oh whatever you come
up with it's not a commitment three
words that you feel now trying my best
love it
I might adopt that I really like it
alone thank you so much for your time
thank you
there was a lot of fun